anyway Color Purple what a great movie I
think it's time they remade it oh are we
lucky
aren't we lucky first trailer for the
new color purple
I like that the Warner Brothers logo
like if if I just saw the Warner
Brothers logo I think they're making a
new Joker
or like a new animated Batman movie like
you know I was like oh okay Batman and
he's like oh
today our teacher talks about a place
called Africa
this summer gets purple
two purple two colored purple
go back in time you're like you're right
it's a magical place would you like to
go back
where's our Easter fear when you need
him with a boat
today I teach at times about a place
called Africa
[Applause]
[Music]
first off first off
this is not what it was like they they
have this and it is not what it was like
stop it you're [__] revising your
freaking mother doing it again
where's the ritual sacrifice
she say our mom has come from Queens
over there
did you know African you know Africa
don't have no age of consent laws either
we don't want to talk about that though
African queens lived in mud Huts
that means that we
royalty
oh yeah they're doing the wee was Kang's
joke on ironically are you [__]
serious well I mean we was Kang started
on ironically because they keep doing
the Weaver's Kings that's true they just
won't let it go
[Music]
I
trailer core trailer core trailer court
like you do understand right that in
doing this you cheapen
like the actual feelings and and
memories of slavery like the original
color purple right like it was the
trailer core of She [__] hates how
could you imagine
oh no puddle of Mud sharks no it just
goes ebony
yes no no but it has to be lost
[Music]
I
don't need
Hey Now You're an All-Star get your game
on
and slam and welcome to the jam
if you Steal My Sunshine
I know it is
um okay no more though guys enough New
Kids on the Block had a bunch of hits
Chinese food makes me sick
we don't take you seriously anymore
um
I like the way you work
No Diggity
Molly Percocet Molly Molly Perkins what
about this uh
uh [__] uh you could do like my way
with Limp Biscuit my way or the highways
fighting flavors yeah
it's gonna be all I want for Christmas
is you I
I can I hate this
it doesn't it doesn't matter what song
it is what I know is that I hate it but
hear me out hear me out what if I got it
I got it what if we fix it we can fix it
here we go
I got you
[Music]
thank you
oh this is gonna work oh this is gonna
work I found a trailer core version of
my way oh my God I was joking
[Music]
I got it
yes I'm marking out right now
[Applause]
it's gonna be rock stone cold all over
again
[Music]
it works look
s because it's the same cookie cutter
[__]
okay this is perfect I love this
oh no oh no is it gonna be a slave show
okay
[Music]
hahaha
okay come on this is insane you are in a
dangerous game we gotta know our place
dude it it's amazing how trailer it
almost does make sense from a business
standpoint to just be like boom bomb
bang make a trailer let's go
oh [__] this is so dumb it's gonna kick
in right on time wise
[Music]
this is so [__] dumb
oh this is so good I want to see it
you're right now I want to see the movie
[Music]
I don't get what's the man remember
Fantasia barino dude first time holy
[__] that's a blast from there that's
the new Little Mermaid by the way that
you're looking at there that's that's
the whatever her name is yeah that's the
Little Mermaid one here okay sorry guys
I didn't mean to cut the trailer off
let's have to see what's going on
my way was better right oh hands down I
mean my to be fair though I mean what's
gonna compete yeah it's a good point
that means me a while I need me a wife
even if we have the part you and me I
just have one heart I wonder if they
leave in that scene shave my face
how about the Oprah Winfrey peeing one
oh yeah
yeah
[Music]
I'll write you every day
nothing but that can keep me from it
wait are they lesbians no is that what's
happening there are they lesbian blacks
I don't [__] know anymore man
oh
you must ain't got no Kinfolk around
these parts all I had was my sister
she was the only one ever loved me
wait so you had the same origin story as
Johnny Cash yes
but you know what we're so stupid and I
just thought of something and maybe this
will work maybe it won't but let me let
me try this we picked the wrong song
Because Hollywood is hack right
let me try some things
here we go
here we go let's try this
Purple Rain
Purple Rain okay let's give this a shot
foreign
oh yeah this is gonna work I already
tell
it always works of course you're right
this is why now editors probably don't
make any money because they're like you
could you could have that trailer done
in 30 minutes
it's raining
never meant to cause you anything and I
like it's a White Guy saying
let's face it princesses princess white
bro come on let's be realistic here he's
a gay white guy
[Music]
on these parts all I have because that's
what black people said they said Kinfolk
that was me like this is this a lesbian
thing again man who knows anymore so so
the plot of Color Purple is basically uh
these two poor black sisters uh this
farmer comes along and he's like I want
to marry you and the older sister's like
nah and and runs away because he's
abusive and [__] and he ends up with her
sister and it's her trying to like it's
it's literally just like coming of age
so it's not really about anything well
you know those movies where it's like
you're yeah
what is this look at this this cannot be
historically accurate hold on
I mean the former slave rolling up in a
Rolls-Royce like a drag Oh no I got a
drag queen boat what's this one on well
forget the boat they pull up in a
[__] rolls at one point [__]
Stevens this is fiction why would Steven
Spielberg be involved in this again oh I
have a good idea
because it's anti-white subversive
[__] I was gonna say a good
situation because he's Jewish that's
actually the simpler yeah
Believe it or believe it or not there's
the roles so believe it or not I'm
actually I'm weird I'm actually reading
the plot right now of this there's like
there's like no white people
it's literally just about them being
horrible to each other then I just go to
Chicago
well that's cool all right all right
this is good leave us out of it that's
hey I'll take it no there might not be
no I bet you there's white people in it
I guarantee you there's a white people
at a diner or there's gonna be a scene
but at least most of this [__] will
just be like black on black like it is
in real life
reading the plot there isn't even a
moment in the plot where it's like she
comes across some races that it's
literally this this girl running away
from home and then going through all
these like coming of age [__] it's
more boring than I actually thought it
was this is [__] awful